and so god can you imagine the shock
david can you imagine the shock of
firing off the gun and realizing that
you just killed somebody and everyone
around you is panicking and freaking out
and you're just like
well that's first of all
that's so [ __ ] ridiculous in the
first phase that first place even if
it's a problem right the fact that they
have live rounds there it should never
[ __ ] be on set like right like why
the [ __ ] is there a live round on set
that's wild to me yeah they said they
were doing target practice or something
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast we have a very
very special returning guest once again
we have big
boss bows can i just say that do you
know the origin of that name at all no
it was supposed to be a joke
because because like i'm 4 foot 11 hence
the big not true and then boss i made
that when i was entry level at smosh so
it was funny because i was i was like
the most entry-level person so it was
big boss bows it was supposed to be a
joke the whole time and nobody [ __ ]
knows like i mean i don't i don't know
like i think that like everyone actually
thinks that i think i'm like
this [ __ ] could seem like
we need to talk about your [ __ ]
prison life right now with your 17
tattoos no but you know what we really
need to talk about david
the show our show
our show our live show
i was coming
it back [ __ ]
[ __ ] on [ __ ] let's do it dude look l.a
kind of opening back up well except for
like for the show you have to have your
covered vaccination card like you have
to have it or you have to have some kind
of digital thing or something like that
but as long as you have it come on get
in here enjoy the show like bro i i've
been so excited for this for like
honestly david i've been excited for
this for like a year or two like ever
since i worked at live nation i always
wanted to do a live show bro i need to
be on a stage it's fun like listen
geniusbrain has never done a live show
so this is what it was the best way to
[ __ ] do it i'm super excited i've not
too many people do live podcasts and
i've been asking like advice from other
people they're like we don't know
they've done it they're like we don't
know what works we're just putting it
live and everything's so [ __ ] new
nobody knows what they're doing right
now with it but i mean like it's fun
like i mean like really the show is
gonna be well i have some segments first
david i've already planned some things
out david's letting me run everything so
i want it to be super fun my goal is to
always make sure everyone's having
really fun like a lot of fun so i think
it's gonna be sick but yeah it's mostly
gonna be us doing this except in person
and like the room is really big we ain't
gonna sell this whole room out okay
that ain't gonna happen i was i wasn't
even with him i'm like can y'all close
off the balcony but honestly dude i
could yo when we we sold out the front
row in like the first 30 minutes i could
not [ __ ] believe it a lot of the
tickets are gone though dude
yeah thank you guys oh my god i'm like i
keep waving and then like my like fat is
jiggling here and then my tattoo
i've been getting mad chunky lately this
coved weight has got my ass really well
i was looking at old videos you know
this is what i hate about youtube it
catalogs your life specifically your
weight and so like prior to covid before
i was doing all the food stuff i was
kickboxing all the time jiu jitsu doing
all sorts of [ __ ] and then you don't
realize how much weight you gained
because it happened so slowly and then
recently
i had to go to a wedding and i tried to
put on the suit that button was gonna
blast the [ __ ] off
just pictured it
no like it it when i went to the wedding
i couldn't button the suit so i had
three days before the wedding was
actually there because i had i wasn't
part of the the party
so i was like my star myself for three
days just so i could fit into this
[ __ ] suit and it was so hot in
sacramento that by the time the wedding
hit i sweated all my fat off just barely
enough where i could [ __ ] sit and fit
that suit
[ __ ] covered david walking around the
wedding like this
i
they're like yo what's wrong with this
guy he's like us for your steven your
posture has gotten better
it's for your safety
for your safety cuff
but why you get so many tattoos for
oh [ __ ] dude i okay i yeah i kind of did
go a little ham with it i i got you had
zero [ __ ] tattoos the last time i saw
you i'm here for genius brain to catalog
my life like dude i definitely come here
through phases of life and that's why i
came back so soon because now i'm a
jailbird
but the last time it was maybe a couple
of months ago people usually get one
they chill out for a little bit and they
get another one you got [ __ ] four
okay so
this isn't that interesting but just to
explain it i just so i didn't get
tattoos for like oh like i i think i got
one when i was 18 then i didn't get any
for like 11 years and where's that one
at um i have one on my back oh yeah i
have a tattoo on my back that says
vicious i'm not kidding i don't give a
[ __ ] um
everyone's like you're gonna regret that
and then we'll get there but like so for
many years and actually i'll talk about
this because probably a lot of other
people like me too my mom was like what
she would like shame me for tattoos like
why did you get
she would like be really disgusted or
you know people would be like oh you
need to get a job all this kind of stuff
and then um so i got really scared to
get tattoos because i didn't know what
my trajectory was gonna be and then my
youtube channel kind of blew up and then
i got like some other offers and some
other things and i'm like okay so i am
doing this forever so i finally just got
the tattoos that i've always wanted so
the reason i got so many so fast is
because these are all tattoos that i've
wanted for the past 10 years but i was
too scared to get and then i just fired
off and got everything i wanted you got
to explain them because they look
intricate as [ __ ] dude that's the other
thing too i'm so happy i waited until i
was in my late twenties to get tattoos
so you could afford a good idea
good ones yes this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
expensive david hold on can you look at
these bro look at this one like well
actually it's behind like the plastic
because that's just crazy isn't that
insane yeah yeah and then this one this
was the first one [ __ ] nut same chick
that did this one and then like this one
this one's peeling but you can just see
like all the fine lines like that the
thing about tattoo is i don't understand
how people i can't draw on [ __ ] paper
how the [ __ ] do people do that i'm
scared this is my mask because on the
camera it looks like i just left my
drawers yeah
it does
where else did you get a tattoo this is
my
is my mask y'all that'd be weird if it
wasn't i'm sorry david
like how much does it cost how much
first of all i don't even know how much
tattoos cost because i've never had one
honestly these were pretty expensive
because of how intricate they were yeah
because they look gangster as [ __ ] if
you wanted for the video like the higher
quality ones so people won't see though
but this one cost me about 700
which is quite a bit but for something
i'm gonna have forever i want it to be
beautiful i want it to be like artful
you know um this this text one that i
got this one was only like 300 but it
was done by a really good guy that does
like single needle pokes that's the most
gangster [ __ ] phrase why the [ __ ] did
you get that on you that's just so
threatening no prisoners no mercy
because i mean it oh my
i told i told you this david like i mean
i mean that [ __ ] like i'm dude you know
me i'm ride or die i'm ride or diet [ __ ]
right and it's like once i connect with
somebody and i'm like okay we good we
good great but if something happens and
you don't want to be here anymore if you
don't want to ride anymore i'll double
check with you and then we're done yeah
and like that's you know that's right
i mean that's how i am but you're like
that too yeah but i don't know if i
could get a tattoo on it because that
should make me nervous yes i feel like
when they put that on me people were
like oh you down to fight and i'm like
no man it's just cute i am
i know you are you [ __ ] scrappy
little [ __ ]
the [ __ ] to be that one looks painful
that one this is this one dude this one
did it did hurt but i mean we did it
what is that but so okay let me tell you
what this is though because it's
actually kind of crazy so this is the
tattoo of anna varney cantadia who's the
lead singer of this gothic rock band
called sapporo turned us in the ensemble
of shadows now let me tell you why this
this [ __ ] just said 18 words i don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on she's a
musician right okay now let me say this
homegirl she came out in the 80s in
germany as transgender that is the most
gangster [ __ ] i've ever heard like in
the 80s bro in germany but
trust me she went through a lot and so
all of her pain that she went through
she translated into her music and it is
some of the most it's gothic so like if
people don't like that kind of stuff
like whatever but um her pain is in all
of her music and it is beautiful and
like i love true artists like i love
them so much and so like this is like
the strongest woman in the world to me
so i want to pay homage damn dude so you
actually get tattoos that have like
legit [ __ ] meaning like it's
important to you oh yeah a lot of people
don't do that now they just get some
random cute [ __ ] and they go why did you
get that they go it was cute oh
bro i mean yeah i've been thinking about
this [ __ ] what are those then explain
those ones
so this one's a this one's more of like
a religious but also an occult piece
i've talked about this before i have a
lot of religious trauma religious trauma
has defined my entire life and a lot of
times when people are hurt by something
they try to take the power back from it
so my way is adorning myself with kind
of christian symbolism and i plan to
have a lot more of it as well um and
then this one is a plague doctor do you
know what plague doctors were
i no david let me like this is all like
this just is crazy but also they look
badass as [ __ ] right you can't stop
looking damn you like my ink thank you
they look they look like art pieces
that's so interesting thank you so much
see isn't it sick i waited till i was
older yeah because all the homies who
got like tattoos when they were 17 they
look like 17 year old tattoos right and
they took up all the good real estate
and like as much as i want to get more i
want to like wait a minute because like
what if i have more ideas and get more
into the tattoo artistry i love the
spacing on these ones wait i'll show you
guys a little bit yo i was this dude the
other night he was like this is giving
me angelina jolie vibes and i was like
thank you oh he's trying to [ __ ] for
sure
[Laughter]
let me tell you all about the plague
doctors though okay so back it way back
in the day when the bubonic plague
bubonic bubonic plague was happening
right
they're like everybody's getting sick
and they're like oh [ __ ] and the
doctor's like yeah let's check this out
and then they're like oh
everybody's dying the bubonic plague was
not playing around every single person
was [ __ ] dying people already weren't
showering back then dead bodies
everywhere decomposing all this [ __ ]
right and so the doctors they go into
the councils like the government and
they're like yo
let's level here for a second we're the
doctors we have all this information we
can't go out there because if we die you
guys will lose all the medicine so we've
got a solution we'll get some of the
villagers we'll teach them about
medicine and then we'll send them out so
then they found people that were willing
to
risk their lives to learn to possibly be
doctors to learn from these doctors and
then if they survive then maybe they
will become that but the main goal of
the main thing of the plague doctors
unbeknownst to them was really for death
tolls so what they did was they took
these untrained people and kind of told
them hey here's how you heal the plague
and then let us know how many people are
dead and they would send them in with
these masks that that thing with the
beak yeah yeah and at the end of it
because i said the the smell of the
human bodies was it was terrifying to
people like uh that all the flesh that
was like dying so they would put incense
at the end of that beak so that they
couldn't smell it as much and the plague
doctors could go around and kind of do
their thing so that's just kind of
that's what that [ __ ] beak was for
yeah
oh my god it's just creepy as [ __ ] i
love it though is it not bro it's hard
as [ __ ]
how long did they take each how long
does it take so this one took about six
hours um and then i'll send you pictures
of you by the way and then yo this one
was eight hours because it was like very
delicate and then here i want to get
like an impressionist portrait like a
painting in here like so that's not done
yet
oh yeah i'm gonna add something to it
bro yeah i'm how many tattoos are you
gonna get i don't know i just i another
thing too i'm in love with people's art
lately and there are so many tattoo
artists that are like true artists i
want to start combining travel with
getting like a tattoo so like there's
some people that are like out in like
copenhagen or like korea that are like
the best [ __ ] tattoo artist like
their work is just so insane and unique
and so i would love to make it a thing
like oh i might go travel here and then
i also get a tattoo by like this crazy
artist and stuff so how do you have a
conversation with your mom who already
hates you getting tattoos from you going
to like one on your back to like 70.
well also
look my mom she's gonna have to deal
with it too because i told her that i
told her like a month or two ago yeah oh
yeah at first first she had to deal with
the boots and then like a month ago i
called i was like hey mom i went on a
date with a girl last night and she was
like
okay did you have fun and i was like bro
we made it
we made it
she's not freaking out about [ __ ]
anymore no
no
not anymore she's really not i wonder
what that switch was for her though like
what made her just be like you know what
because clearly i'm doing things right i
mean did your parents not have that like
flip too oh we got into battles though
like battles like screaming battles like
it took a it took a lot of like fighting
and not talking to my dad for like a
whole year he kicked me out of the house
type of deal so oh [ __ ] but how good are
you guys now like if you went on a date
with a man and you called him would he
be like okay david oh no if i told him i
wouldn't
have hey
we're not at that point yeah like if i
call my dad look dad i'm getting some
fresh dick right now
you don't have to say fresh no i gotta
say like that
i'm getting [ __ ] squeaky clean dick
right now
what do you have for dinner penis and i
just hang up no i'm not gonna
my dad because my dad's still uh he's
still a pastor
david his dad hangs on the phone
yeah he's just gonna die he's like what
what
no
he said he's not having that time
like if i i mean me doing comedy and you
know being who i am right now is already
kind of hard for him to handle you know
he just got okay with that if i threw in
the gay thing in there he's definitely
killing himself
like if i if i if i turned out to be gay
i got to keep that [ __ ] to myself for
the sake of him living bro it's it's
still sad dude because like we accept it
obviously but like our parents were like
okay all right you know what why don't
we just let them
move on
but my mom's like okay fine whatever you
want to do now so she still does she
still go to church oh yeah she's my mom
my mother is a god-fearing christian oh
she's like one of those people oh yeah
oh yeah yes she was never trying to be
like but you know oh my whole life why
you think i'm about to get all these
religious tattoos bro but hey look now
the the bank rolling in mom where you
want to go you want to stay in virginia
you're going to be in la when you're 80.
huh just play nice she's like
you're going to go to hell it's like do
you know how much i'm making you know
hell's temporary you know
you might be able to talk the same maybe
concept it's just a theory that's crazy
though that's i mean people who are
hyper religious really don't
accept that yeah i know i know but i'm
shocked yeah but it's also i don't know
i feel like
this podcast is brought to you by daily
harvest my friends for me this time of
the year usually means getting back into
a busier schedule you know what happens
in the holidays you get busy and the
last thing i want to do is worry about
having bomb ass food that's good for me
that's going to take forever to make
well daily harvest helps fix that
problem in my life daily harvest
delivers delicious harvest bowls
flatbread smoothies and much much more
organic fruits baby vegetables oh guess
where right to your freaking stupid door
that's right we're talking about
convenience listen
if the food services that i'm getting
isn't convenient and it doesn't taste
good i don't want it well daily harvest
clicks and checks those box specifically
i love me their spinach flatbreads that
spinach flatbread is fluffifier not only
is it for fire it's super easy to make
because it's already done for you and
guess what i know it's going to taste
good because i trust daily harvest that
all the delicious foods are built on
whole organic fruits vegetables that
conveniently stays fresh in my freezer
so it's ready when i'm ready that's
right [ __ ] enjoy this time of year
even more like i do with daily harvest
go to
dailyharvest.combrain to get up to 40
off your first box that's
dailyharvest.combrain for up to forty
dollars off your first box
dailyharvest.com
brain
david what you've been up to lately me
tell me something crazy nothing crazy
much what's the last thing that made you
mad
everything
dude that seems like such an easy
question for us but i'm like where do we
start you know what's been really
[ __ ] irritating me though like
so i i felt i thought i had coveted like
a couple weeks ago right so i was like
oh [ __ ] i got the vid
anytime i feel sick i feel like i got
the big the vid the vid the video i got
the kovi's got the vids
i felt like i had the kobe's so i'm
going there i got checked like three or
four times within the span of a week i
don't have it and you know now it's like
mentally starting to [ __ ] me up yeah
because i think i have covered and then
you know i go to my primary care doctor
he's like listen you don't have [ __ ]
covet stop coming here you know i'm like
listen
one more time just swap my [ __ ] real
quick
but then david we don't have to go
through the ads i just it's just my
preference no put it open me up
so i uh
during this time i felt a little funky
what it was i was just i was just
[ __ ] exhausted right cause i was just
doing too much [ __ ] so i'm like okay i
just got to sleep and rest the [ __ ] off
well during this time i started going
through the internet i don't really
watch youtube videos much like that okay
but for some reason on my feed all this
like political stuff started popping up
which is not stuff that i normally look
at but one of the things that started
irritating me was
how people uh debate
have you seen these like political
debate videos oh yeah of course it's
kind of crazy how
like young college students will debate
people you know it's always like the
right versus the left type of stuff
right and how they come there to debate
somebody but they come completely
unprepared with facts oh
man okay so one of my one of my really
good friends uh
his name's destiny he's been doing like
politics and like debates and everything
like that for like like [ __ ] 10 years
on the internet
bro he literally just like decimates
anybody but i've when i started watching
those things i noticed okay so there's
this one debate of these two people
about veganism and really all it is is
the battle of the egos okay they just
collect a little information and then
it's like you get lucky if this if
person a collected this information that
counters person b and they get so
excited because they got that gotcha
moment yo i'm tired of people's gotcha
moments like shut the [ __ ] up like
they're so excited to win like uh and
i'm i'm dude i am so i hate that [ __ ] i
hate i'm not into the debates one of the
biggest things that i saw and i'm pretty
sure people know about this but you know
you know who uh jordan peterson is yeah
so jordan peterson he was having a
debate with uh somebody from the uk this
is the video that blew him up oh i know
exactly you know
several times i only saw that a few
weeks ago really and i was like okay it
was just a small snippet i was like let
me see the whole interview so i watched
the whole thing from beginning to end
i never wanted to slap somebody so
[ __ ] hard in my life this woman had
lost her mind she was so you know so
what you're saying is
so what you're say
it's literally the most childish debate
tactic i've ever seen from an adult
who's supposed to be of higher intellect
she like went in with like i've got four
different avenues for gotcha moment she
was like sitting there beforehand
shuffling a paper she was like i'm gonna
decimate this little [ __ ] when he
comes in and then he comes in and she's
like hi doctor jordan peterson she's
just like got all of her gotcha moments
ready but he's just there to have a
conversation yeah like that you know
that was the interesting thing right
because i think jordan peterson like i
don't know anything about jordan
peterson yeah see and also i'll say this
david and i are talking about a video
that came out years ago i keep looking
at the monitor and on the camera but
dave and i are talking about a video
that came out years ago since then he's
had a lot of controversy i personally
have not kept up with jordan peterson in
the past two or three four years david
obviously clearly hasn't either we are
just because i know that there's some
kind of [ __ ] going on with him right now
but i just want to be like we don't even
know we're just talking about that one
[ __ ] talking but let's keep talking
about that video because that's just mad
funny it was so funny because it would
i just don't expect that from somebody
to who has like a political platform to
come so unprepared you know what i mean
also too by the way this is this is
literally what she was doing it was like
so jordan peterson would be like i don't
know the sky is green so what you're
saying is blue is for racist
[Laughter]
and it's like yo what the [ __ ] are you
doing wait give me give me like a random
line and i see where her arms are like
her like just give me like a random
thing okay
you mean what jordan peterson would say
okay i believe that men and women are
equal
so what you're saying is that you want
to
kill so what you're saying is that women
are only equal to men if men exist and
women can suck dick
dude that lady that i i think you know
what it was though it was her coming
into it with the
confident like she beforehand and also i
i want to say that interview was in like
2016 maybe or 2017. yeah i mean it was
in the height of me too and everything
and the pendulum was swinging hard that
way however you know as ridiculous as a
lot of things were that were going on
back then were um it is a good thing
because the pendulum has to swing like
hard left or hard right like to make a
change in something right and then
eventually it starts to level out and i
do feel like we're starting to like
level out from that whole era too yeah
it's this weird idea of
i think we're in this weird space where
the idea of somebody having an opposing
thought is considered uh like violence
now like that's like the hot word like
and i was you know obviously i'm going
through this rabbit hole right i'm
watching like all these videos from you
know people on the political left
destroy somebody from the political
right and then i'm watching these bit
and both of them do this thing where
they specifically choose the the idiots
of the other side to debate which is
kind of dumb like you know what i mean
sometimes sometimes they can't find
people that accept it that will actually
do it that are on the other side like
the simple thing of like
just having somebody exist that can
disagree with you bothers people and i
don't understand what the [ __ ]
problem is a lot of people so those
beliefs they have they tie their ego and
their identity to those beliefs so when
you attack those beliefs they feel like
you're attacking them and they have to
defend them at all costs i'm not saying
it's accurate that's so stupid i would
never tie my identity to a belief
because then you're basically saying
it's gonna make it eight times harder to
change that belief later and i've
changed so many thoughts like five years
ago i used to hate cats i lo my [ __ ]
tank of okay i love that man now i was
literally just christian
like that i love cats now and five years
ago i would you know i didn't like
animals a long time ago because like i
had my own problems and like i didn't
you know this was such a weird thing i
felt like um i was like unlovable and i
didn't deserve love so it bothered me
when animals would come to me so i would
reject the animals you need another
tattoo for that
that's what these are all for that's
[ __ ] crazy but that i know some
people are like that i mean david i have
ptsd okay my brain's like all kinds do
you have any idea how [ __ ] loving
animals are like that stupid-ass dog
outside
when i was feeling under the weather
like i couldn't figure out why this dog
wouldn't stop cuddling me and i i have
like i get hot so i'm like get the [ __ ]
away from me like i'm pushing this dog
away but i think it could sense that i
wasn't feeling well so it kept on
sleeping next to me and i clicked in my
head because my dog back at home would
always do that whenever i was sick it
would always come close to me and
snuggle try to keep me warm and so
that's what that dog was doing and i was
over here you know slapping the [ __ ] out
of it get the [ __ ] away from me but he
was trying to show me love i hope you've
been yeah like now i'm like i'm all
about receiving love and giving love all
about it before i wasn't but yeah i love
animals now too but yeah people don't
that'd be so weird to tie your whole
identity to those beliefs and and then
you know and and i saw this a lot with
like and i think the reason why this
stuff started popping up was because i
i'm pretty sure it was because i was
watching all these videos about the dave
chappelle special and you know you know
people saying that he's transphobic and
that kind of left to all these like
political thoughts and so that's why all
these videos were popping up but even
with like the dave chappelle special
it's opened up this huge can of worms
when we're talking about the whole the
trans debate which i don't even know
what the debate is about really when i
was when i watched the special
because everybody's saying that he's
transphobic you know his
this is just we're in line with comedy
and jokes that people are saying like
you shouldn't cross and when it comes to
dave chappelle some people are saying
you shouldn't cross yeah why i don't
know
i i don't [ __ ] know so
it's like who's who's sending down that
decree um well the thing is is i didn't
watch the dave show like everyone was
talking about the dave chapel special i
haven't watched it i haven't seen the
joke i that's why i haven't made any
like comments about it i think i'm a
little nervous too to be honest because
it could be really bad i mean i have a
trans woman tattooed on me you know um i
don't know how i'm gonna feel but one
thing is is that like dave chappelle is
a huge part of my own childhood and my
own development when i was growing up
when i was 10 years old i wasn't allowed
to watch south park or like any of the
cool shows but i was allowed to watch
dave chappelle because he was black and
so when i got to school i my mom's super
christian i couldn't watch all these
other shows i was i was able to keep up
with the jokes when everyone watched the
chapel show on friday and they were
making jokes or thursday coming in on
friday i could be joking with them you
know i know what the episode was i'm in
on everything and then also
like i grew up in southern virginia dave
made it cool to be black it changed
almost every like oh my god i almost
like teared up a minute it literally
changed almost everything for me in
school and so like
for you know a whole bunch of people to
like come in and be like well you you
can't support him you can't like him you
know because because of my trauma and
i'm like well what about how that healed
part of my trauma and so i you know i
feel it's like we're not gonna
invalidate our like
you know our problems with each other
but so i've just kind of like stayed
away from it because like you know it's
a special place for me i mean the the
biggest thing i think that a lot of
people are talking about and something
that i really brought up it's
how do we go ahead and pick and choose
which trauma is okay to make fun of
right because a lot of comics will talk
about them getting their ass beat uh
[ __ ] being broke as [ __ ] [ __ ]
white people beating their ass but
everybody cracks the [ __ ] up right
but the inclusive part about this and i
think that what a lot of comics are
saying along with dave chappelle it's
like listen
if i can make fun of these groups and
everybody and my group too i should be
able to make fun of you you're included
in this because you're being recognized
as a person everybody can [ __ ] get it
including you guys including my people
including all white people mexican
people whatever group that you identify
with everybody can [ __ ] get it in
comedy and the fact that you think that
you could exclude yourself because you
feel offended well you were laughing
about me earlier yeah why is it okay now
yeah
so this conversation is very weird why
do we get to pick and choose which
trauma it's okay to make fun of exactly
only because it hurts you in the moment
that it is now yeah and it's like
everyone's just a little bit different
god i get so nervous talking about these
things because like i feel like they can
be taken out of context and they're
going to be like oh bose is this or that
like you know someone asked me what i
thought about like this whole like black
fishing thing with something else well i
you know what it's so interesting
because i had another situation where i
did feel appropriated by somebody it
wasn't for black it was for something
else you know and i did understand what
it felt like for the first time to like
feel kind of appropriate but then on the
flip side when i first heard of like
black fishing
people don't understand your experience
if you're a black woman that grew up
around a lot of white people no one
wanted to be me nobody wanted my lips no
one wanted my skin no one wanted
anything and so to see people trying to
look like me is it's like it's not
offensive it's actually almost
flattering to my childhood brain and i
can't do anything about it you know and
so it's like you should be mad about
this and i'm like well i'm just gonna
have to be neutral about it because
actually i never experienced this before
where somebody wanted to look like with
me like people i used to hate my lips i
still remember like a journal entry i
wrote just how sad i was about how big
my [ __ ] lips were really oh yeah did
people make comments about the ways
always was it women or guys oh it was
everyone they were gonna look at girl's
lips and be like no that was that girl
could suck something
but that was the thing too the white
boys they would say i had dsls always
dsls and like that's like not you know
that's like not cool even yeah yeah yeah
it's weird so i don't know i i have a
weird i just wish that you know how
people feel about things they they can't
dictate how you take whatever happens to
you in your life and that's the weird
thing they go oh you should be offended
but i'm not so what the [ __ ] are you
going to do about it you're going to
make me offended yeah
or i have to forget my trauma or my
healing or my things for yours i can't
let you know what i mean it's like well
then how about we both just put our guns
down and walk away and that's what i do
and it's so weird because these people
want to fight for it but then i'm like
well i don't know i guess i minimize my
own things but though you know dave made
it cool to be black and and and seeing
people that want to look like a black
woman is like new to me i'm like well it
like it's more like it does something to
like my child brain like my inner child
that's still there and i can't explain
it like how like that that beauty
standard constantly shifts right and i
think like when people get so hunkered
down on what what beauty is now it's
like you might regret that 10 years from
now because that might not be the
standard yes
exactly and i was actually saying this
the other day when you follow a meta
like no matter how popular it is if it's
like something that's permanent whether
a video you put online or some surgery
that you alter yourself with like you
know how every girl got the ariana
grande face like four years ago and now
they're trying to keep it up and they
look they're looking all crazy david
they're looking all crazy like people
getting like hella fillers out like 24
and then they got to keep it up and
their skin's shifting and they go to
different surgeons they're like not
always good oh my god bro
you like you're
how are you gonna reverse that you can't
though i mean like i see it now right so
there
are women who are friends of mine who
are very [ __ ] beautiful they've
always been beautiful even as they get
older they're still beautiful but
they're trying to hold on to something
that you cannot hold on to which is time
and age those things just it progresses
and it slips from you that's all that it
is and you're beautiful in a different
type of way yes so so it's like
when i see this happen right and i saw
it recently with somebody who i haven't
seen on instagram in a very long time
and she's
to me like just from a physical aspect i
think she's like ideally just very what
everybody wants in a girl in terms of
looks wise right but she's getting a
little older and i didn't see any age in
her but she felt like it was and then lo
and behold filler filler filler lips are
huge now and i'm like
what happened like why did you do this
yeah right and it's like this beauty
standard that she feels that she has to
keep up with right because this is all
this is what i'm worth like this is what
people value this is so this is how i
value myself or feeling like well but
also to be fair some people just like
the look like i have a friend that her
lips just keep getting bigger and she's
like i love it and i'm like okay like
you know dude i get that though too
my lovely brain farts before we continue
this podcast once again is brought to
you by four sig matic if you don't know
what four sigmatic might let me tell you
something four sigmatics mushroom coffee
is [ __ ] amazing it's a coffee it's
real organic fair trade single origin
arabica coffee with lion's mane mushroom
for productivity and chaga mushroom for
immune support i have been starting my
day with four sigmatic if it's not
matcha it's going to be for sig matic it
tastes good and on top of that the
lion's mane makes my brain super snappy
and smart i'm telling you the way that i
feel when i drink this stuff is
fantastic it's almost hard to go without
it i do it cold brew style i just steep
it overnight and the next morning i'm
ready to go i add a little bit of almond
milk maybe some oat milk to it because
your boy lactose he be farting listen
we've worked out an exclusive offer with
four sigmatic on their best selling
mushroom coffee but this is just for
genius brain listeners get up to 40 off
plus free shipping on mushroom coffee
bundles to claim this deal you must go
to 4sigmatic.com
brain genius this offer is only for
genius brain listeners and is not
available on their regular website
you'll save up to 40 and get free
shipping so go right now to four
sigmatic that's f o u r s i g m a t i c
dot com slash brain genius and fuel your
productivity and creativity with some
delicious mushroom coffee but i i think
i think you're absolutely right the
beauty is like different at different
ages this is my favorite age like i
literally feel like hotter than ever
like i'm having the most [ __ ] fun
i've been going to the gym i can get my
legs like big as [ __ ] bro i've been
working on my abs bruh david they should
have never gave me blonde hair it was oh
my god
station has said no we can't give it to
her dude bro i don't know if you noticed
but i literally got this hair and then i
got my little gold septum ring i started
getting my tattoos i started going to
the gym but you know what it was it was
part of me i was like i want to feel
more confident in my appearance and i
just picked out everything that i didn't
really like and i was like i'm going to
fix this this this this this and i feel
great well yeah i mean that's like a
certain level of like you know what you
like and you can change these things
that you don't like about yourself which
is pretty awesome right and i think that
sometimes too like when we when i talk
about this like you know cosmetic
surgery thing the the argument behind
that is like it's my body i can do
whatever i want a hundred percent no i'm
not saying you can't right i just have a
thought about it like i think about
myself as because i'm a man and if i
have a daughter what does it do to my
daughter's future in terms of how she
views herself and what beauty is right
yeah because when i st and i think this
is an issue that happens in big cities
if you go to i'm pretty sure when you go
back home or whatever you don't see
people with mega [ __ ] [ __ ] done to
their face but in these metropolitan
cities you do and people think that this
that la new york chicago whatever this
is how the rest of the world thinks but
it's really not the case when i go back
home to sacramento everybody looks a
little different and it's [ __ ]
amazing to me because it's beautiful
like you get to see different faces and
those different faces is kind of what
makes people beautiful like you don't
look like the every other person walking
down the street and so we went from a
shift of like appreciate what god has
given you or whatever if you don't
believe in god or what you're born with
and you're beautiful just the way that
you are to versus like hey
i'm [ __ ] ugly i got to look like
everybody else and have i got the money
for you shut the [ __ ] up and let me do
what i want
you know i'm like oh like i don't know
what that shift happened i have found
that there are so many ways to be
attractive when we were growing up it
was really just like like what does
their face look like right well
like confidence is super sexy like as
you get older like people start to build
up their businesses and their like world
and their jobs and stuff and it's like
even people that don't like feel like
they look attractive on the outside you
start to see it in their posture and the
way they carry themselves and the way
they keep eye contact like that
confidence is super hot or i've noticed
that like people that dress really well
i was seeing this guy a while ago who
like she's like a little bit older but
oh my god he could [ __ ] dress like he
had like gold jewelry on and [ __ ] like i
was like i was like this is
yeah and he smelled good as hell i loved
that [ __ ] or like you know what like a
good a good haircut or maybe it is the
face maybe it's the fillers maybe it's
the tattoo like there's so many ways i
feel like to be attractive or just go to
the gym a couple times a week like
you're like your face could look like
anything and you could just give
yourself a hot body like i feel like
girls are a lot more forgiving in terms
of like the physical looks realm than a
lot of like some of these guys are a lot
of the guys are not trying and i'll say
this too just because
i always see a bunch of like dudes that
are probably some of the most ugly
[ __ ] ogres i've ever seen in my life
but they'll see a fine ass girl walk by
and they're like you don't know what i'd
do with that it's like you've never been
offered the [ __ ] are you talking about
you [ __ ] gremlin like you know but
that's like guys aren't as forgiving as
women are because women can look at a
dude and see value in other things right
whether it's a job whether it's a career
whether it's confidence how they how
they speak to you you know the way they
can invoke an emotion out of you can
really change the perception of what
attractiveness is
for a guy
for i think when you're young like
younger men
it's just looks that's the first thing
that grabs them and that's the thing
that matters the most uh i'm not saying
that's how it is for all guys but when i
was younger i was definitely like that
and i too was an ogre
what i expected out of the girl that was
that i wanted to be with i didn't expect
out of myself you know i think that's
like a young guy thing i don't know what
the [ __ ] that is but girls have always
been way more forgiving i get that i
yeah i've had
dude wait last time i was here do we
talk about like i'm not dating anymore
at all no
for real no
why no well i was in a four-year
relationship i was i was in a
relationship the entire time i was out
here in l.a like for real oh yeah like i
moved out here within six months i got
you know i started dating and i'm the
type of person where like if i date you
we get married like we ain't wasting no
time like i'm not planning to just date
for two years like we gonna bond we're
gonna move in together we don't have
babies you know so like this was like
[ __ ] bro she really does live that
tattoo life like yo yo [ __ ] when we get
together to get married okay
hey you wanna get married yeah yo whip
that dick out put it in my mouth let's
see what's up put it in there pull it
out buddy yeah hurry up come come hurry
up
it's going like this the whole time what
is she doing i know she's kind of hot
though um but yeah so i got wiped up
real fast we did it for four years and
um
he was uh it was for the most part like
a pretty good boyfriend but uh we
obviously had our things but what i
mostly realized was i was growing into
his lifestyle like beverly hills like
housewife like i was always getting jobs
that were only in beverly hills i was
like trying to look a certain way for
his family i never got tattoos because
of that like they were they said that
like the graveyard that their families
buried in you can't have tattoos and
stuff and so like i wasn't i didn't want
to get piercings because i didn't know
how his parents would feel clearly this
is what i want to look like right so i
and amongst a lot of other things i was
working corporate because i felt like
his family respected me more if i did
that i was growing into a life that was
not mine
and so i broke up with him and i just
said i like didn't want to date anymore
i wanted to like go off and do my thing
and build myself up and and become more
individualistic and then you know maybe
when i'm in my like mid 30s i'll settle
down to somebody because when i when i'm
when i'm about to date like we in this
for the long run but i'm gonna be single
for a couple years so i've just been
like so what do you mean by dating
though like uh like seriously looking
for a relationship or do you mean can
you just like date for fun
like see like seeing people or hooking
up yeah
i well actually this is really funny i i
get buried in work a lot so like i'll go
months without like hooking up with
somebody or something like that you know
like literally months like
f five six i don't and i don't even like
think about it or anything but like i'm
very demisexual i have to at least kind
of like somebody like i don't need to
like have a full-on crush on you but i
need to like you as a person i would
like to be biologically attracted to i
said biologically like like i mean i
don't know why i said that jesus
i need to be biologically attracted to
you i need to want to mate with you on a
biological level
with this with the electric temp thing
and just temperatureing his balls let me
see the heat of these things
he's doing like a pheromone test
uh your results came back positive you
can come on over to 11 o'clock tonight
jesus [ __ ] christ
[Laughter]
you may come over at 11 o'clock and [ __ ]
thee
my word you're probably over here like
you're gonna send me pictures or nothing
no
no absolutely not bro that's the thing
too yeah i don't that's why i'm boring
too because like i'm not gonna send
nobody no pictures do nothing i just
don't we're in that technological state
you start sending out tit pics you're
[ __ ] you know where it's going well
yeah and also like i feel like
just because i do online stuff like
hooking up with people randomly is a lot
more high risk for me it's like some
guys and like this is [ __ ] true some
dudes will do weird [ __ ] like have sex
with you and record you like
it's true like it happened like
especially if they know that you're like
that you never [ __ ] know like people
really do weird [ __ ] or you know they
want to prove to their friends that
they're really talking to you so then
they'll send you send you know your
pictures or something and i've seen it
happen to my friends my friends have got
might have a friend that's gotten
recorded before like two years ago and
so and there's you know then like set up
a camera somewhere and then record it
that's [ __ ] crazy dude
and it just came out i was like she
didn't talk to the person for like a
year and some change i'm like i should
talk about i think
she didn't talk about it for like a year
and some change and then um and then
like it was like they came out of
nowhere like with just like some threats
basically i don't want to give anybody
any ideas maybe she cut off no but no
that happens a lot there was a there was
like a korean pop star too and she was
an american girl uh she was underage and
then her
ex-boyfriend
really after she became a huge k-pop
star [ __ ] release these photos of her
naked but she's like 16. so she's
underage at the time
so it's like yo what the [ __ ] is this
guy doing and then you never know there
was like a text thread about him giving
it to trying to sell it to like certain
um
like publications like how much can i
get for this you know blah blah blah
blah like i had these photos
and then people you know they screen
recorded or snapped and he sent it out
because this person thank god was like
hey if you put this out you can be in
some big trouble you should you
shouldn't do this stuff he goes yeah but
you know if i get a lot of money it'll
be worth it type of thing but he's like
no you're going to get in trouble
because she was underage those pictures
of her when she was like 16 years old
and started fully naked like
the [ __ ] is wrong with these people well
i like and him trying to sell that it's
like hello possession of child
pornography or yeah like what the like
yeah we're both like why yeah
yeah it's just it's really weird i
that's that's why i'm just like scared
of stuff like that so i'm very cautious
but you know if i do like date or hook
up with somebody or something it's
usually somebody that i've been talking
to for a long time we have a basis of
like a friendship or something and like
i don't know like it's just yeah i don't
i i really don't like damn there's a lot
of work though it's so much a lot of
people don't understand that like dating
is [ __ ] work and i do not but that's
the thing i don't want to grow into
anybody's life right now i need to be
myself and be fully individualistic and
then i will come together with somebody
when the time is right because the
person i am right now and the person i'm
gonna be in five years are two totally
different people so how could i possibly
settle down with somebody right now at
29. the other thing is i think i might
have talked to you about this before i
think the thing that teaches you the
most about yourself are relationships
relationships are what push us further
into our self there's nothing that has
taught me more than a relationship the
breakup from the beginning to the end
you know and so it's like if you're with
the same person for like 20 30 40 years
you guys have to keep going through
trials and tribulations to feel that
growth humans have to feel growth we
have to feel like we're progressing and
so you're just going to have to be
starting [ __ ] with your not starting to
be going through [ __ ] with your partner
constantly every couple of years to feel
that whereas if you're kind of like
dating and then on your own and then
dating it on your own you're gonna have
so many experiences like
yeah that's definitely happened to me
like i
we my ex and i broke up like almost a
year ago and i've kind of like loosely
like dated two people and i've learned
so much about myself just from those
months or two of like hanging out with
them it's insane well yeah that's what
dating does like yeah
and i need more of those experiences
because i need to know who i am a lot of
young people too like i always tell
people not to get
caught up and just think that the first
person that you're with is going to be
the person you're going to be with for
the rest of your life because you don't
know if that person wants to grow with
you you don't know if they're going to
grow up to be different people and on
top of that too like even when i first
met mariel when when we were first
dating and before we actually decided to
be a couple and be together she was like
very apprehensive about it and the
thing that i told her off the jump
because i got kind of tired of her not
like this like committing and i was like
i don't have time for this i was like
listen like i think you have something
very confused
i'm not dating you to find out if i'm
good for you i'm trying to see if you're
good for me like i don't know you enough
yet to worry about you i'm worrying
about myself right now so if you think
that you could just
have me here and just wait for you
that's not going to happen
and so
that's the thing i want people to
understand like i've learned more about
myself than i have about than about her
yeah everything that i've learned
through myself in the last six or seven
years was because of the relationships
that we were in yes and listen we've she
and i talked about on the podcast we
almost separated for real for real like
in just like in the last year it was
like we're done we're not going to do
this anymore but it took that and a lot
of for us to separate and be you know
reflect on this for us to come back
together and be a little stronger but
these are all growing pains like if
you're not willing to do that
i don't know any single like strong
relationship that hasn't gone through
that
i don't know a single one i don't know a
single one that where people didn't have
these like breakthrough moments
constantly yeah because you know a lot
of people like in social media they
don't talk about this [ __ ] you know we
know people who are very good at posting
their photos of like listen we're
[ __ ] amazing oh my god
dude you know we know the difference
breaking news to all of you if they're
posting pictures half time it ain't real
bro
i feel like a lot of times couples tend
to post pictures almost at the most
vulnerable points you know like when
they're trying to like tell their
partner like oh i care look i did the
thing you know what i mean or like oh my
god it's so funny because i'm on twitch
a lot so you probably don't see this too
often so many streamers date each other
and then the typical you know statement
comes out blah blah blah and i've
decided to split amicably we still have
so much love for each other but we've
decided to lay everything to rest after
three years come on y'all [ __ ] hate
each other you hate each other you hate
each other we still love each other
dearly i mean like granted what else are
they supposed to do drag the public into
their drama but still like i kind of
hate that it's teaching people society
taught us a lot of things about love and
relationships that were not true and we
are now doing that to everyone else
we're creating this new fabrication
almost and like saying oh yeah you can
break up with somebody after two three
four years and have love for them and
move on amicably that's what we say
publicly
that's what some of those people say and
they're little twit longers and [ __ ]
like that and then you're teaching
younger people that like oh after your
four year breakup you and your ex are
still gonna be best friends and then
when that doesn't happen to them they're
going to be confused and so now we're
the ones painting society for them
that's not entirely correct every person
that i've broken up with if they died i
would not know
i literally wouldn't [ __ ] know
because here's the thing this is what i
believe anyway see i understand that you
guys grew together but there's a reason
why you guys split you don't have to be
friends because if i'm not a part of
your life your life will still go on
yeah nothing bad happens of me not being
in there you're fine so i'm fine it also
makes it just too more complicated in my
new relationship where i have to explain
why this person who my penis has been in
her mouth repeatedly is still around
here
yeah exactly especially when you get
somebody else what what is that people
say something oh if they're if they're
not friends with their exes that's a red
flag actually it's the other way around
yeah if you're friends with all of your
exes still those are the sociopathic
[ __ ] that are just keeping a
whole bunch of people on a string
attachment issues dude yeah
i yeah who the [ __ ] like people saying
if you're not friends with your ex
anymore red flag that [ __ ] is cringe
cringe guys and i'm actually my ex of
four years still a friend of mine we
went to the gym a couple weeks ago like
he's actually actually is a homie but
it's because we kind of split for
different reasons we didn't split for
fighting and [ __ ] like that we just grew
apart you know so stuff like that sure
you might be friends but like so many
people end up leaving toxic
relationships and they try to be friends
after cut that [ __ ] off i'm okay
off that [ __ ] dude i'm a hundred percent
okay 101. listen if you dump me well
we're definitely not friends well i
almost said
101ps stupid
and you normally start saying it
i've definitely every girl that i've
either broken up with or the girl that
has left me we're we're done we're done
i don't hate you i just you know what i
just don't need you my my therapist told
me this thing was really interesting i
was telling her this was like a couple
months ago actually also i'm gonna break
i'm on hiatus from therapy right now i
didn't even know that that was a goal
that people should have like being so
happy that your therapist is like do you
really need me right now yeah well you
know michelle i'll come back in a couple
weeks i haven't been back for a while
i've been [ __ ] chilling yeah um but i
was going this was like a few months ago
and i was talking about a person that i
had met and i was talking about the
confusing feelings i had towards a lot
of things and she asked me do you see
this person being a short-term person in
your life or a long term and i was like
i never thought of that before because
when any anyone enters my life and i
like them i just start to assume long
term i just do but when i looked at this
person i was like
this is a short term person but there's
you know something fun here and i've
started looking at that with a lot of
things and then i also realized that
your actions can dictate whether your
relationship with that person is
short-term or long-term and like that's
become a very powerful tool for me to
evaluate lately i was just talking about
this on the previous podcast and some
people didn't understand what i was
talking about when i was saying that
there's different levels of friendships
and connections there's
acquaintances there's
long-term acquaintances there's homies
there's the homie homies and then
there's friends all different categories
it doesn't mean there's nothing i don't
mean anything by it it just is what it
is i think a lot of the times people
take these relationships and they all
categorize them in one thing yeah and it
causes them to get hurt by other
people's actions like i always say too i
think girls tend to do this a lot is
where they [ __ ] on the first date they
they meet a girl they connect with them
and they go
besties and i'm like [ __ ] don't
do
that that and yo the ones that spark up
the fastest the ones that fizzle out the
fastest 100 10 000 wait 101 bucks
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
that is
101p [ __ ]
you'll see it you'll see it happen right
they always go oh my i can't believe
that she did this to me of course what
do you mean you don't know her yeah
y'all just met a month ago we were so
close we hung out every night yeah y'all
knew that [ __ ] was gone yeah and then
also a lot of people trauma bond very
quickly in the beginning and they don't
realize that you know trauma bonding is
the [ __ ] worst because once you guys
figure that [ __ ] out you guys have
nothing left yeah like what's your [ __ ]
you're just gonna meet up and just talk
about the trauma 24 [ __ ] seven oh
yeah dude you guys share nothing in
common in that you know i i thought i've
had to consciously break some trauma
bonds that i've shared with some people
you know like it's really weird and like
you guys that like people like listening
that are trauma bonding is really like
hard to explain but it's like basically
if one of your trauma like triggers is
activated like let's say a abandonment
or something like that um like let's say
that you're with a friend or so [ __ ] i
don't know explain it let one of yours
is abandonment and then the other friend
that you're talking to is also
abandonment and you guys kind of have
that same trigger activated at the same
time and you're you're in that mental
place and then you talk about it you are
now trauma bonding like it's almost like
your inner child are like connecting and
it's
very powerful and it can make it can
make things feel familiar you know i was
talking about this the other day
sometimes you meet people that feel
familiar and comfortable but it doesn't
mean it's a good thing it could be they
could remind you of the person that hurt
you the most and like you could be like
oh
maybe i can redo this maybe i can redo
this trauma and maybe they won't leave
me this time and then but what you're
doing is connecting with a person that's
very similar to the person from 10 years
ago that hurt you and you're seeing
those same traits but you're not
connecting it and realizing it and then
that person leaves and it's like a
[ __ ] domino effect it just like cuts
you down dude i've been trying to watch
out lately for familiar people to figure
out if you're familiar good or familiar
bad 100 and i um so
a few months back like uh i'm out with a
couple of people this is kind of so
funny that you mentioned this
it's there's like certain things that
happened to me when i was younger that
it was during a time i didn't like who i
was right so it's like i grew up in a
you know precarious neighborhood you
know my the neighborhood where my house
was was fine but where i was kicking
that wasn't that great and these people
were people that i was always pretending
to be something that i wasn't right a
lot of like thuggery [ __ ] a lot of bad
people right i wanted to be a part of
this group i felt safe i still i felt
very protected but at the same time
super [ __ ] uncomfortable like for i
told the story on the podcast where when
i was i remember the first time these
group of people uh they were a very
specific uh set in sacramento that they
were a part of i i was invited to a
house party and this place is [ __ ]
dirty as hell i still i can still
remember what the place smelled like
like there's just like spit on the floor
drinks everywhere a bunch of [ __ ]
dirty ass looking [ __ ] and dudes okay
you know like just [ __ ] chilling and
i'm sitting here just i look like a fish
out of water but i'm trying to like you
know what's up cut like i'm trying to be
all over hey
you know i'm trying to be all hard as
[ __ ]
but i told the story on the podcast
where there was this dude at the party
he had these white air force ones you
get nervous i am there white air force
ones on and this dude spit on the floor
and this guy spit on his shoes
and i knew this guy right and he looked
at him and he goes
clean my [ __ ] shoes
and you know i'm just like what the [ __ ]
is going on and i'm sitting in this
dirty smelly ass [ __ ] cigarette
smelling couch just sitting here like oh
what the [ __ ] is going on but i'm trying
to keep my cool right he goes clean my
[ __ ] shoes i'm not cleaning your
[ __ ] shoe dude literally stands up
strapped up like 20 dudes around them
all strapped up
and they stare at the guy and i'm like
i'm about to witness a [ __ ] murder
and i'm sitting here unless he cleans
some shoes yeah and then the guy [ __ ]
got on his knees
got a napkin started cleaning the new
shoes
told him get the [ __ ] out
and then i just sat there and a little
pee
okay he started coming down the side of
my leg cinematic is david's thigh in
just one single drift yeah you know but
i'm still trying to be hard i'm like
yeah [ __ ]
in real life i'm like oh [ __ ]
yeah
once again that i just that reminded me
of that you know what i mean but we're
talking and we're chopping it about all
this other stuff and we have like past
stuff that kind of connects us right yes
you know just the [ __ ] that we used to
do things that we hung out but then as
i'm talking to this person i'm starting
to feel really [ __ ] uncomfortable and
i'm like i don't like this feeling like
what is this like this feels familiar
but it feels familiar in a bad way ooh
okay you know and i started getting like
ptsd i started sweating a little bit and
i'm like oh i'm i'm
and these guys are starting to like me
you know i'm like i i don't want to be
your friend yeah yeah
like i'm scared i'm getting tangled up
into something and like if i try to
ghost them they're gonna be like we're
david yeah exactly all these thoughts
are going through my [ __ ] head and
i'm like why am i here like why am i
connecting to these dudes why am i
having a quote-unquote good conversation
with these people these are not the
people that i want to associate with
yeah i reminded myself of when i was
like 15 years old i felt like a 15 year
old again it was really [ __ ] how long
ago was this it was like a like maybe
three or four months ago
right and i'm over here and then you
kind of like hear the way that i speak
start to change a little bit like how i
used to speak when i was in high school
right i'm like it was good man you know
also they could [ __ ] you know and i'm
like i don't even like talking like this
anymore yeah what am i doing and i'm
adapting to these people because i
because of that weird familiarity yeah
and you feel like you're going back
because it's easy for you to sink into
but you have to make a conscious choice
not to go back into what's easy for you
right that [ __ ] was traumatizing as [ __ ]
that's scary that was so reason too yeah
oh my god can we talk about alec baldwin
oh
yes what what
the [ __ ] [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] okay do you want to go
first for me
you can go first
what the [ __ ]
dude okay in all seriousness so okay
like on my a lot of the stuff that i do
on my channel is actually really trauma
like like trauma related i do a lot of
trauma work and so when i was thinking
about this i do um i also do a lot of
drama where i try to get into the
emotional state of things like victims
like things like that and the first
thing i thought about was okay david
imagine you're at home you have wife and
kid you know whatever your kids your
kids
at home you know you're there you're
chilling your wife's at work the safest
place she could be and you get a call
and they're like
um
your your wife is past like your wife
it's just like what and like before you
even have time to like let that sink in
and they're like she was shot what she's
at work like that's like the next level
of it and then afterwards you get told
that it's by a famous actor and it was
an accident it's almost like it
invalidates all of the shock and pain
that you just like like like society's
telling you that you have to minimize
that because it was an accident and it
was this you know this guy they went out
to lunch the next or din breakfast the
next morning with alec baldwin and i get
it but it's like
my god and then like from alec baldwin's
point of view and i mean like sympathy
all around can you imagine just being on
set this is how [ __ ] fast it happened
the the prop master literally handed it
to him said cold gun alex [ __ ] points
it shoots it and like i don't know
exactly like what but like he shot it
into a house where there were two other
people he just like shot it and all of a
sudden somebody's dead and he's now a
murderer by classification like you just
went from actor to murder whether it's
manslaughter accident you know anything
like that that's another thing too he's
gonna have the best attorneys in the
world but it's manslaughter it still is
everybody on that set is getting [ __ ]
sued
what i i heard the the the person who
was dealing with the weaponry was
somebody who was super inexperienced
so
24 years old or something possibly the
way that it works in la is back in the
day the prop master handled everything
but then uh they had to there was this
mandate that came on that said that you
have to have a prop master and then an
armorer that it's under them that
handles all like the guns and stuff so
what had happened was like some of the
people on set were doing some kind of um
test firing little just practice
shooting with live rounds and so that
got mixed up in there and they said but
they say on set they yelled to alec
baldwin cold prop before it went into
his hand and so god can you imagine the
shock david can you imagine the shock of
firing off the gun and realizing that
you just killed somebody and everyone
around you is panicking and freaking out
and you're just like
well that's first of all
that's so [ __ ] ridiculous in the
first phase the
first place that even if it's a prop gun
right the fact that they have live
rounds there it should never [ __ ] be
on set like right like why the [ __ ] is
there a live round on set that's wild to
me yeah they said they were doing target
practice or something and they're
right and they're supposed to have so
for like film and tv they're supposed to
be three different types of like fake
bullets different velocities that create
different effects but yeah they they had
live rounds on set and i just
i can't dude i can't believe that that
one
hit how did you feel when you heard
about it well listen i've
this is a big conversation that opens up
about like set etiquette and how people
are treated right so if you guys have
never been on film or if you haven't
been on film sets
you know it tends to be kind of harsh
specifically to people who are pas and a
lot of like staff and crew when it comes
to film
it tends to be a little harsh right it's
it's very high tense situations you know
people are on a budget everybody's
getting yelled at people are on the go
go go go go
well
a lot of stuff is coming to light like
hold on a second we shouldn't be
treating people like this right and the
crazy thing is what people don't
understand
america is a lot nicer than it is out in
other countries
like in asia specifically you know like
jackie chan jackie chan doesn't even
like filming in america because
americans have laws about people having
lunch time rest and all this other [ __ ]
because in china it's like you do this
all day until your [ __ ] feet fall off
all day like 14 15 hour days it's insane
yeah so jackie chan because jackie chan
is who jackie chan i'm not saying i love
jackie chan i'm just saying like this is
he likes because he's a perfectionist if
he's doing like a stunt work if that
person has to do it 86 times that
person's gonna do it 86 times until we
get this perfect shot and the culture is
different out there in the states they
don't have that it's like listen now
you're being abusive so
knowing that that even that in this
country we're supposed to be nicer that
people still
don't have like a certain level of like
decency and standard of work when it
comes to sets like
one of those shows that i loved working
on was um that leftover show the netflix
food show and the biggest reason why was
because of how staff and crew were
treated everybody was so respectful and
nice and everybody felt heard it was
super [ __ ] dope to work with that
company yeah but i have been on film
since where i've worked as a pa and
people talk to me like i was a piece of
[ __ ] like they would [ __ ] scream at
me they would yell at me and this is
like my first day as a pa i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm doing i'm fresh and
people are supposed to show you the
ropes but they'll call you stupid they
call you dumb lazy tell you hurry the
[ __ ] up it's like yo is this just how i
was supposed to be and because i thought
that's how it's supposed to be i just
took that [ __ ] i'm like i gotta pay my
[ __ ] dues well now we get to see what
happens when people aren't doing their
[ __ ] job right people aren't getting
paid correctly they're not taking the
right safety precautions somebody can
[ __ ] die
and now what yep and now what like oh my
god dude
like and i think also like in la people
a lot of people that are working like as
a pa or maybe maybe the person's armor
i'm not sure a lot of people in the more
entry-level jobs on set they don't want
to do that job they're trying to build
up to the next thing and like they kind
of just come in they're getting paid
union for like you know 300 bucks a day
actually they they had a lot of people
on set that were non-union yeah i think
because you're all
is it because it's cheaper yes dude yeah
so they said they were cutting corners
on that set i mean oh my god for a lot
of indie films people do have the cut
corners like if it's an indie film it's
a [ __ ] film with alec [ __ ] baldwin
dude i know dude that oh my god that
whole scenario made me so sick did it
make you guys sick i need to know i'm
sorry i'm always talking to people i
mean people people
it's weird right like
i
i don't understand why the [ __ ] they're
alive i just can't wrap my head around
that part who the [ __ ] was the one that
was like hey let's do [ __ ] some
target practice with this real gun here
and just let's just do it why why why
like but i think the other thing that
[ __ ] me up about it too is like how old
is that like baldwin like what like 60
50 something he's like [ __ ] 467 years
old yeah let's say he's 60 or something
like that right now imagine you've lived
this long life you know you've had
scandals you had people hating on you
but you're still an actor you're still
doing your thing you're still alec
baldwin and now this this is just change
i would
what i don't even know what i would do i
think i would just crumble like i don't
know how i could
i don't know that's [ __ ] that one just
stretches i don't know if i could live
with the fact that i killed somebody i
don't think so i don't think i could
that would be i do not know how i would
this is
therapy
extensive therapy for me because i don't
know how i would deal with that
especially someone who was innocent
somebody
like and they died because of me because
of something stupid that i did yeah
right or even if it was somebody else's
fault right it's a collaborative thing
but like he's going to blame himself
like entirely for sure
like i
oh man i then that stuff [ __ ] you up
forever i have a friend uh it was my it
was my old roommate from when i was in
when i was like 18 and i lived in
virginia he was the coolest guy in high
school he was the coolest everyone liked
him like super fun super funny and i
love this guy to death but we kind of
like disconnected like over 10 years ago
and earlier this year we reconnected and
at first there was that familiarity
because this is somebody that i lived
with for like over a year we worked
together we worked the morning and night
shift together he was like one of my
really closest friends and we
reconnected and we spent like two weeks
together and he was not the same person
anymore he had completely changed
because five or six years ago his best
friend had died and he's like told me
before like he he talks about this stuff
all the time because he doesn't know
what to do you know um his best friend
died and he was there when it happened
he actually pulled him out of the water
and he was the one that said let's go
swimming and he's never gotten therapy
for that situation i've been trying to
get homeboy to get into therapy for
[ __ ] years but like those six years
have absolutely destroyed him like the
every time it comes up on june i mean he
just like curls up into a ball basically
completely different person i i mean and
and so like that's what i'm saying with
this alec baldwin thing and we're going
to see this in the media like over the
next five years kind of how he's not
going to let him leave it down
i think there was like a lot of people
too who i think he posted a lot of like
anti-gun like rhetoric and tweet so you
know people from like the hard political
right are ripping this for a new one
it's like [ __ ] man this guy is gonna
have to live with this trauma man
yeah i dude that this one yeah that one
is [ __ ] that is heavy a lot of [ __ ]
up [ __ ] going on in the world man and me
doing all this true crime stuff i've
been learning i've been learning a
little i don't even know how you do all
this true crime stuff because oh yeah i
was gonna ask you about that that
youtuber girl who um who was like a van
life girl well there's a lot of
different parts around it i so i
specifically didn't cover that case
because of how much social media [ __ ]
it up so here i'll tell you this is a
really interesting thing david so the
guy brian laundry that you know
allegedly killed her there's no
confirmation they're saying his remains
are found now blah blah blah who knows
it was really his remains
um
but
they there was a woman that after he
allegedly committed the murder of gabby
potito
a a woman that had a tick tock happened
to see brian laundry and just think he
looked like a nice upstanding citizen
that we get very
nervous
tends to think he's like a nice
upstanding citizen she gives him a ride
somewhere and drops him off and then the
girl afterwards when she realizes that
she picked up a possible murderer the
first thing she does is she goes on
tick-tock and she starts making
tick-tocks about how she picked him up
and what he did and how much money he
had and what he was wearing and where
she picked him up and where she dropped
him off and then she started saying
donate to the fun the help find gabby
fun donate to this and she keeps posting
all these tick tocks about it
go to the police go to the fbi why did
you make a video about this and you know
she didn't go to the police because they
would have told her it was illegal to go
put this information online i i was so
mad about this video because i'm like
you single-handedly just delivered all
of this information to his defense team
and you just [ __ ] them like why would
you do this and that's what like
everyone was doing online they were
digging up like her like social media
posts his posts things like that and i'm
like if i was his defense attorney i
would pay some kid 20 bucks an hour and
i'd be like run through everything
online and figure out what we can use in
our case find out everything that they
know and that's what social media [ __ ]
that whole case up but if brian's really
dead you know
i i got very passionate about that
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah can you
believe that she put it on tick tock i
have to like get away from the mic
because i'm so [ __ ] mad about that
and like the exploit of nature that
people had about that case is absolutely
[ __ ] disgusting i that one made me it
made me so [ __ ] mad and then you know
a lot of another thing too that people
really got wrong is uh people started to
[ __ ] on like cappuccino by saying oh
missing white woman syndrome what about
these people what about all these
missing people blah blah blah well
actually let me i'm gonna actually like
defend that for a second it's not really
missing white woman syndrome it's that
people people feel that emotional pull
towards someone that looks like they
could have been their friend and because
there are just so many white people that
are like seeing this young girl they're
like oh sheila and it's like everyone
has met somebody that looks like gabby
before everybody this is why she
appealed to them she looks like a girl
you'd be sitting next to in school and
so when you find out she's missing and
all this it's like oh my god i could
have known her whereas unfortunately for
some reason when somebody sees somebody
like me they don't they don't know where
they would have seen me so they don't
connect with me as much and then they
just kind of skip over my case and it's
not saying so she's a lightweight
celebrity like she's an she was a
youtube van life person she had a
following so that's spicy yeah so she
didn't think she did i think she was
like i think i think the media put that
in headlines because it sounded good
she wasn't that big of a following i
have not found any record of her having
any type of youtube channel oh i thought
she was like a van life girl people yeah
the media put her up as a van life
youtuber but i couldn't find anything
like other stuff yeah i got interested
because i i saw i used to follow this
girl who was also a youtube i like i
love van life [ __ ] me oh me too
did you watch janelle so
there was a girl who was a youtube van
life girl who i followed for a long time
and she hadn't posted videos in a while
and i'm like what happened to this girl
and she [ __ ] killed herself
yeah she committed suicide are you
serious yeah so like i was like how did
you find out
i found out because i was looking up her
name and it was a while ago now
i feel sad i used to watch her all the
time i can't remember her name i'm
blanking out right now i i was a little
sick a couple weeks ago so my brain's a
little foggy but
she ended up committing suicide and so i
was like what the [ __ ] is going on with
this when they said she was a van life
person too i'm like is there is there
something that people are escaping from
that they have to do this van lifestyle
yeah i don't i don't know what the van i
mean i no i get it because like if
someone just handed me a converted van
no if somebody drove it for me maybe but
like i get it because it's cool it's
just sick like the way like everything's
compartmentalized like why did you i
mean you watched it for a while like i
love it well i
i had a honda element and i loved that
[ __ ] car right and i wanted to
convert it or whatever but that car was
a piece of [ __ ] it was it was just too
much work to fix it up but i like it
because i like being off the grid
originally this podcast i wanted to
build a huge van and make it a mobile
podcast that's cool but then i i kind of
gathered how much it was going to cost
it was a lot of money
this is a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ] money it
wasn't worth it you know so i was like
okay i'm not gonna do that but i love
like the whole van life thing how you
can live off the grid people the way
they build their [ __ ] is [ __ ] yeah i
think also the kind of the appeal of the
whole van life youtube thing is i'm
living my best life i'm having so much
fun look at this look at look at it
you know and like that [ __ ] feels good
and also they're doing some stuff that
you and i would never really do like we
wouldn't go off the grid like that would
be off the grid in front of my house
yeah we yeah just set up the van up
there i'll just be outside of my hou in
front of my house i'm like you know what
i just want to get away from mario for a
second just
hop into the van
maybe go to a park somewhere or just
like camp here and there but i'm not
gonna live off the grid [ __ ] i like the
grid the grid's nice
i appreciate the grid i see well that
was the thing too like when you told me
about that like it just what the [ __ ] is
wrong with kids man right or just human
beings like that girl just posted
everything on tick tock you didn't
[ __ ] call the cops oh my god and just
so many more people and then oh and then
here's another one too this one really
[ __ ] pissed me off uh people on tik
tok every hour posting
hottest gabby update
honey you don't need no one needs news
from you when every [ __ ] media like
company is covering this case with the
most pertinent correct information
people doing 24 hour live tick tock
streams of help find gabby help find
gabby donate here no your farming likes
your farming comments and your farming
followers [ __ ] you and you know what
else every one of you people that farm
followers off of that off of live gabby
potato streams everyone's gonna unfollow
you because they don't give a [ __ ] about
your shitty ass content because those
are the only ideas you have dude i'm
telling you this so like the other day i
guess i'm so mad about that case david
so it's interesting that you mentioned
that right so there was a there was a
dude on tiktok and i i don't think half
of the people understood why i was
irritated at this i wasn't really
irritated at the guy per se
it was just what he does
is what everybody does now right which
is the idea of
instead of being knowledgeable about
something they prefer to just create
content just because they have nothing
better to do and they're trying to farm
these likes so for example it was
checking herself out or what's up no i i
felt like i had too much raw foot going
on
raw footage yeah dude y'all need to pay
for this
i don't think so you ain't getting paid
that's why i got my [ __ ] feet covered
up
but um
yeah yeah it was a simple video and
people thought the video was about this
guy messing up korean food right so he
puts up this video of this korean soup
dish
and
it wasn't what the dish was he just
looked at a photo and he just started
recreating it and you know he's rolling
his eyes about how delicious it is and
i'm like as a korean dude i grew up with
this food i'm like that's not what it is
so why did you create this video and so
you know i went on this quick little
rant and they're like oh why can't you
just let him enjoy uh making your food i
was like because he's not making my food
your food i was like first of all your
food is this my mother yeah
i was like it's like people can't like
enjoy creating like other people's food
that's not what i was saying what i'm
saying is i'm sick and tired of people
just creating content just to create it
without being knowledgeable about what
they're creating yes you're
misrepresenting my people oh oh yeah you
know where is the passion where is your
and i talk about this all i'm getting
mad dude i'm [ __ ] snarling over here
david you see that [ __ ] i've bro i'm
being real passionate about this i'm a
very passionate person and i believe
that you would have purpose and intent
with everything that you do so for
example with my true crime content it
was kind of i was doing different things
all over for a while and what i realized
is my the thing i care about the most is
like i said before like as a person with
ptsd i think that trauma is the biggest
epidemic and i try to
my purpose is to bring trauma to light
that people might recognize themselves
so that they don't commit violent acts
because of those repressed feelings you
know and that is my purpose and that is
my intent and that is the vessel that
all of my content and all of my words
come through so that way i'm not just
picking up random [ __ ] on a tuesday
trying to like score a couple of likes
you know and that's what people do dude
we're we're just in the boom of content
creation phase and so much of it is
disingenuous not saying like i'm not
trying to gatekeep or say like mine is
like my [ __ ] mine my [ __ ] sucks i'm like
still working on my stuff every day but
people are here that don't really care
that you know what so many people are
making content because they want to be
famous they it's for their ego like they
want to be liked but i think when you
get to a certain point you have an
opportunity to spread a message and to
change something yeah and like i don't
think it's
like i'm saying it just goes back to the
fact of like
people are gonna watch this [ __ ] right
so like yeah your video gets like that
food the video that he did your video
got like what a million views and now
people look at that and i'm a kid who's
korean and they go oh that's what that's
well that's what that dish is this is
what korean food is but it's not
so it's like you just mis-spread
information and now all these people who
are too scared to come to people like me
who look like me for the information
they're gonna go to your [ __ ] little
white face and they're gonna be like hey
you know what instead of actually like
learning about the culture i'ma let him
do the work but he's not doing the right
work so it's not about him creating you
know the food properly or correctly is
the fact that he made himself the source
of the information saying i am
knowledgeable follow me listen to me
make it about making it about themselves
so this is where the issue is it's like
listen if you just made the dish the way
it was supposed to you just did i don't
know one [ __ ] google recipe is all
you had to do yeah that's the smallest
amount of respect that you could have
done because now you have a huge
following and you just misread all this
information
and it wasn't done in comedy it wasn't
done in jest it wasn't like you saying
like oh i'm just having a conversation
with somebody you did a full-on video
recipe about hey i know what korean food
is this is what it is white boy like the
[ __ ] are you doing you know oh my god i
got to see this but he took it down
oh he did yeah cause i [ __ ] reposted
it and i was like the [ __ ] is this wait
did other people comment on it like that
too or they were well yeah because
everybody that would comment that they
loved it like the mill whatever the
hundred thousand views was all white
people
but then when you know korean people saw
it they're like wait you're
misrepresenting our food like don't
misrepresent our food oh [ __ ] yeah so he
deleted and took it down oh so
he's not a bad person yeah at least he
took it down
he's not a bad person he's not an
[ __ ] i'm just saying like just be
somewhat responsible for the stuff that
you put out when you just create things
for likes just because you want people
to
to love you that [ __ ] dies out real
quick you're going to get called on them
this [ __ ] super [ __ ] fast and it
happened with him like he's like oh i
bet you in his mind he's like what did i
do wrong you didn't you're not an evil
person but then people will have
problems with you misrepresenting their
culture especially when you're not of
that culture yeah you know you can i
don't like i said i don't give a [ __ ]
about the food i don't ever gate keep
food i got some delicious [ __ ] korean
fruit from no i know what you're feeling
because before i was telling you that
there was like a small thing where i had
actually felt appropriated for the first
time and i felt it yeah on a spiritual
level i was like what is this and it was
the same exact thing it was somebody
taking a name of something and then
misrepresenting it and saying this is
what it is and i'm like that's not what
it is and i felt like i felt disgust
david that's what i felt i felt disgust
and i felt the need to like defend my
honor yeah that's my next tattoo
[Music]
i was telling people it's not about the
food it's about this idea and it's just
an example of this person doing it with
food but everybody does it in everything
that they do they go oh
it's like a white girl being like hey
how to put tracks in your hair like
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] she she better do it right yeah
you know do it right you know it's like
like hot i don't know how to deal with
black girl's hair and it's like this
white girl it's like
well you know i would want to see i
wouldn't just like you know
ex-communicate
excommunication
but yeah you said yeah you said that you
did it completely and doing it wrong
right it's like okay so
yeah it's cool if you're a hair stylist
and you know what's up but if the video
is completely wrong and everybody in the
comments is like yo so that's how you do
it so this is why it is but all the
information's wrong now you're
completely misrepresenting a culture
because now people believe you're a
source of knowledge and you're okay with
that and you shouldn't be and you're
just like yeah okay yeah like i'd be
like yo just at least get the
google search just like low-key [ __ ]
annoyed at how much we can talk like
like it just it just keeps going like
when you have other guys like bro we
[ __ ] ping-pong so much like you know
what i guess it's just one other person
do you have to kind of like fuel it a
lot because we just be usually a lot we
just [ __ ] be going it's almost
annoying what's the time slot at we had
an hour or something what
oh we had an hour 20. oh [ __ ] bye bye
y'all come to the show
well guys hey
come to the come to the show the live
genius brain show the date live genius
brand it's november 11th i'm pretty sure
it's on veterans day you're probably
already off it's in anaheim look we kind
of put it it's look it's a little bit of
a drive but la can get there long beach
can get there flying in from other
states dude you really yeah oh my god i
would cry dude and you know what we
didn't set up any meet and greet stuff
we didn't set up any merch either well
we don't understand we'll meeting we'll
see them yeah yeah everybody
because yeah yeah as long as everyone's
vaccine coming the room is pretty big i
think the room is like you know like
like 800 or something it might be a
little bit small like we might make a
little bit smaller but there's already
like a couple hundred people coming i'm
like oh my god like i can't believe it
like i can't believe it david it's gonna
be fun yeah yeah it's gonna be fun yeah
but seriously if you don't have your
card you will get like turned away at
the door so get get get on it figure
some [ __ ] out bro yeah that's the that's
the the california rule right now so
yeah make it happen jesus brings every
thursdays and sundays until next year
next year year's going to be once a week
and then yeah where can they follow you
bows
oh oh oh i'm big boss bose i'm like most
of my things and then on youtube i'm
boze does true crime
see you all next time